okay thanks to meet so again my name is
Omar I'm going to talk about the
cryptographic hardness of finding a Nash
equilibrium and this is a joint work
with Neil Baton ski and Alana was in
maybe you can close the door over there
Thanks ok so our story today starts with
game theory with the notion of Nash
equilibrium yeah but pretty soon using
the help of Christo's papadimitriou
we're going to kind of put a side game
theory and move on to talking about
purely complexity theoretic questions
and then we're going to answer these
questions using tools from Krypto ok so
let's go ahead and get started with some
game theory so the purpose of game
theory is to study how strategic players
acts in states of conflict and the way
we usually model these states is using
games where the players have a set of
possible actions and based on the
player's actions we can determine the
outcome of the game and also the
utilities for the different players so a
central notion in game theory is the
notion of Nash equilibrium so a Nash
equilibrium is just a set of strategies
for the different players that are in
some sense stable meaning that starting
from these strategies no individual
player has an incentive to change their
strategy so Nash equilibrium is one of
the most useful tools we have for
predicting the behavior of rational
players and perhaps one of the
properties of Nash equilibrium that
makes it so useful is the fact that it
always exists so a famous theorem by
John ash says that in every game there
is a set of perhaps probabilistic
strategies let's form an equilibrium
okay so in every game there exists a
Nash equilibrium now as game theorists
we may be completely satisfied with such
a statement but as computer scientists
just knowing that something exists is
usually not enough we also want to know
whether a Nash equilibrium the game can
be computed efficiently so here the
answer is already much less clear today
we don't have any polynomial time
algorithm for computing a Nash
equilibrium as far as we know this
problem may be intractable
so understanding the complexity of the
finding a Nash equilibrium is a
fascinating question from a purely
algorithmic perspective but even beyond
that if we do realize that finding a
Nash equilibrium is an intractable
problem this would be a major drawback
for a Nash as a solution concept as a
way to predict the behavior if the
behaviors of players in the real world
and putting this in the words of Kemal
Jane if your laptop can find it then
neither can the market okay so today we
want to understand how hard it is to
find a Nash equilibrium so let's go
ahead and get started with some
complexity classes so here we have the
classes FP and f NP these are just the
functional versions of P and NP they
contain search problems instead of
decision problems and the problem Nash
is contained in a subclass of F and P
called TF NP so TF and p is the class
that contains total search problems
these are search problems that for every
instance there always exists at least
one solution so the problem Nash really
is in TF NP exactly because of Nash's
existence theorem okay so now maybe done
papadimitriou showed that unless the
polynomial hierarchy collapses you
cannot have a reduction from an
np-complete problem to a problem in TS
NP so this means that we cannot hope to
prove that Nash is np-complete but maybe
you can try and prove the next best
thing maybe we can show that Nash is in
fact complete 40s NP the problem is the
suggestion is that we don't really know
how to prove that things are complete
for TF and p we don't even know if this
class even contains complete problems so
a suggestion by Papadimitriou is to
instead try and study kind of large
subclasses of TF NP where we group
together problems according to the type
of combinatorial argument used in there
proof of totality so today we're going
to focus on one of these subclasses
called peapods PPID and as we'll see the
class paper is closely related to the
complexity of nash so very roughly a
paper contains total search problems
where
the totality is proven via parity
argument in directed graphs so this is
still kind of vague so let me also give
you the formal definition so formally ap
but is defined in terms of its complete
problem so people contains all total
search problems that are reducible to a
problem called end of the line so let me
tell you a bit more about this end of
the line problem so this is a
combinatorial problem on graphs so the
input of the problem is a directed graph
and where the in degree and the out
degree of every node is at most 10 1 so
this graph is just a collection of
disjoint paths in cycles and you're also
given a source node in this graph just
the start point of some path and your
goal is to find another source or sink
in the graph just any one of these green
endpoints so you can see that this
problem always have a solution by a
simple parity argument if the graph is a
source it must also have at least one
sink so now if the graph is relatively
small then solving this problem is
really easy so really we're interested
in solving the end of the line problem
on exponential size graphs that are
given to us using some succinct
representation specifically the nodes of
the graph will be represented by n bit
strings and the edges are given to us
using a pair of programs S&P that given
any node V in the graph these programs
tells us what is the successor and
predecessor of this note okay so now the
naive way to solve the end of the line
problem is to just start from the source
and follow the edges of the graph until
you reach a sink but because the graph
is very large this knave approach may
take exponential time ok this is the end
of the line problem now let's go back to
the problem of Nash and see what it has
to do with it so a Papadimitriou showed
that Nash is contained in the class
peapod by giving a reduction to the end
of the line problem and he also
conjectured that snatch is in fact
people complete meaning that there's
also a reduction in the other direction
so 10 to 10 years later
in a remarkable sequence of work the
stock is called brick and Papadimitriou
and Chen and dank improve this
conjecture so they show that you can
solve an arbitrary end of the line
instance by just finding the Nash
equilibrium of some related game so the
bottom line here is that the class
people exactly captures the complexity
of finding a Nash equilibrium and this
means that for now and we can kind of
put a side game theory and just focus on
understanding the end of the line
problem okay so let's sum up what we
already know so we talked about this
class p but it has complete problems
such as the end of the line problem in
nash it's also not to contain a other
interesting problem related to finding
fixed points of continuous functions and
even though none of these problems is
not to be np-complete is likely to be
np-complete so we don't know how to
solve any of these problems efficiently
so we can kind of conjecture that the
class p but really is hard but still
it's someone comes up tomorrow with an
algorithm showing that the class p but
is in fact easy this would be a really
interesting and surprising algorithmic
development but i'm not sure how much it
will affect the way that we as
complexity theorists and cryptographers
think about the world so really what
we're looking for is some additional
evidence for the fact that the class p
but really is hard so a very natural
place to look for such f so for such
hardness is in crypto and the reason
that cryptographic problems such as
factoring discrete log or learning with
there are a good place to look for
people hardness is because first of all
we think that these problems are hard
but they're also not too hard none of
these problems is believed to be
np-complete so a natural question asked
already by Papadimitriou is whether we
can base the pod hardness on Krypto so
this is exactly what we're going to do
today today we'll show that the class p
but is hard based on cryptographic
assumptions specifically we will use the
hardness of indistinguishability of
occasion
okay so a back to our story we started
by asking what is the complexity of
finding a Nash equilibrium we translated
it to a problem on graphs at the end of
the line problem now we're going to show
that this problem is hard based on
indistinguishability of a sketch okay so
I'm going to start with a few words of
intuition about program office keishon
and what does it have to do with the end
of the line problem so if you probably
already know an office skater is just a
compiler that takes a program and makes
it unintelligible so ideally office
getting a program should be equivalent
to taking this program and putting it
inside a black box so now we're back to
the end of the line problem I'm going to
show you a folklore construction of a
hard end of the line instance based on
ideal program of escape so this
construction except from office Cajun
you will also use a pseudo-random
permutation FK and now our instance is
as follows we start with the source
which is just the 0 0 string and for
every node V we connect an edge between
V and F of V so this defines a long path
and the end of this path the sink is
this the pre image of the old zero
string so from here we can't continue
otherwise we kind of wrap back around to
the source so the successor and
predecessor programs that define this
instance they are essentially just
computing the function the pseudo-random
permutation F forward and backwards
except on these end points where we need
to explicitly make sure we don't wrap
around now if I just give you the
successor and predecessor program
including the description of the secret
key K in the clear then it will be very
easy for you to solve the to find the
sink and solve this instance so instead
our instance is going to contain these
programs office cated so now it's not
difficult to prove that if the
sophistication has ideal security if you
only have black box access to the
successor and predecessor program then
the nodes on this path look completely
random to you and the only way you can
actually find the end of the path is by
explicitly invoking the successor
program exponential
normally many times ok so this
construction already gives us a hard end
of the line instance but only based on
this very strong notion of ideal or
virtual black box office keishon and the
problem with this suggestion is that we
don't really believe in idea of
sketching in fact we have several
impossibility result in lower bounds for
this notion some of these lower bounds
apply specifically for the case of
office getting pseudo random functions
so instead what we're going to do today
is construct show the hardness of the
end of the line problem based on
indistinguishability of occasion which
is a much weaker and also more
believable a notion of a Fisk action so
just as a reminder in the signature
beauty of occasion lets us take any two
equivalent programs and turn them into
office cated programs that are
computationally indistinguishable okay
so our main theorem says that assuming
indistinguishability of occasion with
sub exponential security and also of
course one-way functions the end of the
line problem is hard we can even show
that the end of the line problem is a
sub exponentially hard but of course
there is some loss in parameters here we
also show that the end of the line
problem is hard on average so we
construct an explicit hard distribution
over end of the line instances okay so
now a very important question especially
in light of this result is how much
should we really believe in the hardness
of i/o so this is a question that it was
discussed in depth during this workshop
and I'm going to say a few more words
about this in my conclusion okay so
let's prove this theorem let's construct
a hard end of the line instance using
indistinguishability of occasion and as
is often the case our construction is
going to be rather different than the
previous one based on ideal for station
so except from a ir we're going to use
apps to the random function f k so
before we used x to the random
permutation now we're using a
pseudo-random function the reason is
that later in the proof we are going to
puncture this function and this is
that we don't know how to do with
permutations okay so just like before
our instance looks like a long path but
now every note in this path is a pair of
the form i Sigma where Sigma I just
denotes the evaluation of the
pseudo-random function f k on I the
nodes are ordered according to the value
of I starting from 1 all the way up to
some exponential number capital in okay
so now let's write down the successor
and predecessor program that define this
instance so the successful program will
have the secret key K hard coded so it
can compute all the Sigma I values now
given a node i comma Sigma if this is
the sink we just say sink if this is
another node of the form I Sigma I then
we just returned the next node on the
path and you also need to say what
happens if this note is not of the form
I Sigma I meaning that it's not even on
this path so in this case we just make
this node into a self loop by outputting
the node unchanged as the successor of
itself so really our graph looks like
this long path and also many many self
loops and all that adding these self
loops it doesn't really introduce any
new solutions to our instance still the
only sink in this graph is the node n
sigma 0 so now the predecessor programs
is defined similarly and just like
before we don't want to give you these
programs including the secret key K in
the clear so we offer sched them using a
distinguished ability of vocation so now
our goal is to prove that given the
office gated successor and predecessor
programs it's hard to find the sink
specifically it's hard to find the value
of Sigma N and actually we're going to
start by proving an easier statement
we're going to just prove that it's hard
to find sigma n based on the office
gated successor program we're going to
forget about the predecessor for now
so our proof strategy is as follows we
have the successor program is we're
going to prove that it's
indistinguishable from another program s
Prime the program X prime describes a
similar graph except that in this graph
the last node n sigma n is a self loop
instead of a sink so I'm proving that
these two programs are indistinguishable
is really enough because if you could
find the value of Sigma n from any one
of these programs then you can also
distinguish these programs by just
evaluating them on the last node and
testing whether you got a sink or self
loop so we need to show that these two
programs are computationally
indistinguishable and now that these
programs are not functionally equivalent
they behave differently on the last node
so we can directly use I of security we
need to do something a bit more
sophisticated so we want to show that
the programs that describe these graphs
are computationally indistinguishable
and the high-level idea is to transition
between these graphs in a sequence of
very small steps and every one of these
steps is designed in such a way that we
can really prove indistinguishable ax t
of the graphs using io only on one point
they may differ and more all i care
about is that i didn't define the top
graph explicitly but all we need from
this graph is that it is a self loop in
the last note this would be enough can't
you say like di own with one point
listen so this is kind of what we're
saying the crucial part of the of the
proof is to show that it's hard to find
this point so this is indirectly what
we're trying to do ok so I'm going to
describe the sequence of steps and then
I'll prove indistinguishability of every
step so in the first step we're going to
take a random node on this chain and
we're going to remove its outgoing edge
so this essentially breaks the chain
into two parts and what we want to do
now is take look at the second part of
the chain and break it apart edge by
edge so note that this graph already
depends on the random edge that we
removed so if we want to remove the next
edge we can't just apply the first step
again because now the next edge is no
longer random so we need a new type of
step so in our second type of step real
we are allowed to take an arbitrary node
whose in degree is zero and turn it into
a self loop so once we do this once now
we have a new node whose in degree zero
and we can apply this step again you
just apply this step again and again
until we reach the end of the chain so
now that this argument has an
exponential number of step of the same
order as capital n so this is where we
rely on sub exponential security okay so
now I want to prove the
indistinguishability of the two steps
and before I do that I'm going to prove
a more general lemma that is going to be
very useful so the setting of this lemma
is as follows we start with the program
a it's a completely arbitrary program
and we also define another program B sub
RZ that computes exactly the same
function is a except on one input R
where this program outputs see so now
the lemma says that for a random input R
and for every output Z then distinguish
ability of us Cashin of the program's a
and B RZR computationally
indistinguishable so again the statement
of the lemma says that you can take an
arbitrary program change its output on a
random input and this change will be
indistinguishable under I oh so the
proof of this lemma is pretty simple
it's an application of the sparse
triggers technique of the high-end
waters I'm going to skip the proof but I
will show you how to use this lemma in
order to prove indistinguishability over
two steps so in the first step we wanted
to take a random node our Sigma R and
remove its outgoing edge so if our
previous successor program was as our
new successful program is s prime it
computes the same function as s except
on input I equal to R where we outputs a
bot so now these two programs are indeed
indistinguishable exactly
our lemma okay so the proof of the
second step is just a bit more
complicated I'm not going to go into all
the details i'll just give the
high-level idea so in the second step we
wanted to take a note who's in degree an
arbitrary note i sigma i who is in
degree zero and turn it into a self loop
so now the index I is not necessarily
random so we can't apply the same
argument as before but the value of
sigma i is pseudo random so we want to
use that so first we're going to use a
trick called puncturing to make sure
that Sigma I looks random even given the
successor program that can compute all
the other Sigma's and here will be very
important that the in degree of this
node is really zero because if the
successor program explicitly outputs the
value Sigma I then we want to be able to
replace it with a random string okay so
after we establish that Sigma I really
is to the random we can just use our
ulema again to change the value of the
successor program on this note so this
is the indistinguishability for proof
for the two-step this concludes the
proof that we cannot find the sink sigma
n based on the office cated successor
program so we're almost done if you
remember in the beginning of the proof
we made the simplifying assumption and
got rid of the predecessor program so
let's bring it right back so now it
turns out that the proof we just saw
completely breaks down so let me show
you just where it breaks down so it
breaks down in the second step where we
kind of use the fact that if the in
degree of a node is 0 then the successor
program never explicitly outputs this
node but now the predecessor program
outputs this node so our proof doesn't
work anymore so we fought about it a bit
and it seems like just doing more io
gymnastics is not going to help us here
and eventually the surgeon really comes
from somewhere completely different so
so the solution is based on an
observation of
canon valiant so they show that if you
have a path that satisfies some sort of
verifiability property that our
construction does satisfy then you don't
really need to give up the predecessor
program you can somehow simulate it
using only the successor program so this
sounds incredible this is based on a
theorem of Bennett from 84 talking about
reversible computation it says that any
computation can be simulated in a
reversible way by incurring only a very
small overhead so this is a kind of a
very cool theorem if you want to know
more about how we use it in our proof
you're welcome to come talk to me after
or just take a look at the paper okay so
let me just conclude so we talked about
the hardness of many different problems
so let's kind of recap by trying to
follow this hardness so we started with
the problem of finding a Nash
equilibrium of a game we saw that this
is as hard as the end of the pliant
problem on graphs and today we prove
that this is as hard as breaking in
distinguish a billet Association now
today our constructions of
indistinguishability office Cashin are
based on multi linear maps but here the
assumptions that we use are maybe not as
nice or as clean as we would like them
to be yet and our multi linear maps in
turn are based on lattices and again we
still don't know how to base security on
standard assumptions so there is still
some work to be done but the bottom line
is that if you follow this long chain of
reductions you can actually design games
that somehow embed inside them a hard
lattice problems that's it thank